today on the Matt Walsh show with the
government now seizing unprecedented
power in the name of a national
emergency and a threat to public health
we have to consider what might happen
when the next Democratic president gets
into office and decides that for example
climate change is a national health
emergency what happens then we'll talk
about that also five headlines including
medical experts saying now you know
oops turns out you know you know how we
told you guys not to wear masks because
masks aren't effective and they won't do
anything turns out they are effective so
they've kind of changed on that but
there's there's reason to believe in
fact it seems pretty clear that some of
these organizations like WHO and CDC
they were just flat-out lying before and
saying that masks aren't effective to
slow the spread of the disease of the
virus even though they knew that they
are effective so we'll talk about that
and today in your daily cancellation
we're going to cancel a school principal
who warned parents that they should not
attempt whatever they do do not attempt
to teach your own children during the
shutdown you are not a teacher you are a
parent we'll talk about what's wrong
with that attitude plus a whole bunch of
people right to tell me why I'm wrong in
my objections that I raised yesterday to
the government arresting pastors who
hold worship services I'm wrong to
object to that
so says these email or so we'll go
through those today as well but starting
off here yesterday former President
Barack Obama sent out a tweet scolding
President Trump and tying the corona
virus pandemic to climate change this is
what Obama wrote he said we've seen all
too terribly the consequences of those
who denied denied warnings of a pandemic
we can't afford anymore consequences of
climate denial all of us especially
young people have to demand better of
our government at every level and vote
this fall along with this tweet was a
link to an LA Times article about the
Trump administration curtailing some of
the vehicle admissions standards that
Obama had put in place so Obama's point
is that in his opinion a failure to take
governmental action against climate
change will have the same sort of effect
as Trump's failure in his opinion to
take governmental action against the
corner virus now what Obama doesn't
mention it doesn't want us to realize is
that you know among the people who
denied
the initial threat of a pandemic was the
media you know the left-wing medias is a
CNN among them they were they were also
early on saying that this isn't going to
be a pandemic I said it - most people
were saying but but of course Obama
wants to tie it only to Trump now Obama
is hammering on a familiar theme many
media outlets have attempted to link
climate change and this there was a
recent article in Time the article
titled five lessons from a corona virus
that will help us tackle climate change
and it goes through the five lessons one
of the lessons is that global challenges
require systemic changes changes that
can only be activated by government or
companies and the article goes on from
there and says but they also require
individual behavioural changes we need
both we've seen over the past few weeks
that governments can take radical action
and we can change our behavior quickly
al Jazeera has also connected the two
issues much more directly the they
published an article saying the corona
virus outbreak is part is part of the
climate change crisis and we're told in
the article that quote the sweeping and
unprecedented measures taken by the
government and international
institutions to curb the virus should
cause us to quote wonder about another
global emergency that needs urgent
action climate change and then it
continues in fact one may argue that the
pandemic is part of climate change and
therefore our response to it should not
be limited to containing the spread of
the virus what we thought was normal
before the pandemic was already a crisis
and so returning to it cannot be an
option now I could marshal other
examples here but hopefully the point is
pretty clear the left is arguing that
the governmental response to the corona
virus should serve as a basis for the
government's response to climate change
now phrases like systemic changes and
sweeping and unprecedented measures and
behavioral changes these are being used
in a positive sense to suggest a path
forward in our mortal struggle against
the weather
now those of us who historically have
rightfully not been so keen on the
government doing things that are
sweeping and systemic should take note
of this and we should be mayor we should
be quite wary in fact I almost said we
should be married no we should not be
married we should be wary it seems at
this point pretty likely if not in fact
inevitable that the next democratic
president will use the precedents being
set right now to justify dramatic
infringement on our liberties for the
sake of fighting the climate change
boogeyman or any number of other real or
imagined threats and we'll get more into
that in just a second but first I want
to give you a word from red power bikes
you know everybody is uh looking for
something to do right now we're looking
for you know you just want to be you
want to be able to first of all to
release relieve a little bit of stress
is good and we're just looking for
things to do that that that it doesn't
just entail sitting on your couch and
watching screens because I think we're
all doing way too much of that I know
that I am and that's where route rad
power bikes comes in it's just something
fun to do and it's a it's a constructive
healthy outdoor activity we still are
allowed to go outdoors you know in in
most places anyway rad power bikes it's
kind of a cross between a traditional
bike and a moped but it doesn't require
a special driver's license like a moped
would that's a good thing you go up to
20 miles per hour without pedaling so
you can get out and about without
getting sweaty but you're still out
there they're great for commuting also
if you want to get out on on the trail
you know we have a lot of trails around
my house so that's great for that
hauling groceries or even transporting
your kids on the back
unlike other ebikes they're actually
affordable plus to show appreciation for
those that serve us wrap our bikes is
offering $100 off all ebike purchases
for active slash ex-military first
responders teachers and students and
that's great especially now when you
think about what all those people are
doing rad power bikes offers flexible
financing for as low as 0% APR it right
now as a limited time offer get a free
accessory with purchase of a bike that's
why you get a free gift of up
$200 in value and free shipping to the
lower 48 states to get this special
offer just text the word bike to 64,000
that's bike to 64,000 text bike to
64,000 beat i ke to 64,000 okay so we
have to think about this the government
projected that millions would die from
the corona virus epidemic and use that
as a justification for effectively
suspending the bill of rights locking
millions of Americans in their homes
forcibly closing millions of businesses
putting entire sectors of the workforce
out of work arresting pastors quarantine
whole cities even banning people from
you know walking around unless they have
an approved reason many Americans have
approved of these measures despite the
fact that they're destroying our economy
and bringing us closer and closer to a
crash and eventual depression that will
be unlike anything we've ever seen
before so it doesn't take a
fortune-teller to detect where this
might go next if if the government's
projections and models are reason enough
to take this sort of action then and
this is something I think you have to
consider even if you're on board with
everything that's happening right now
you still have to consider this
projections and models are the reason
why all this is happening and we're
going to potentially crash the economy
not potentially we are because of
projections and models then what happens
though when when the government under a
Democratic president projects the end of
all life on Earth unless extraordinary
things are done to circumvent it on what
basis can those of us who endorsed the
current shutdown of American society to
save millions of lives object when a
similarly drastic program is put in
place to save billions of lives I mean
if we're doing this to save millions it
certainly would do it to save billions
wouldn't we if the if the government can
issue declarations that shudder in many
cases permanently tens of millions of
small businesses why can't it issue
cancelling industries that it will say
contribute to climate change and are
helping to bring about Armageddon those
of us who support these shutdowns at
that point I think we're gonna be in
quite a bind because we're not going to
be able to argue that the government in
principle should not or does not have
the power to toss free enterprise into
the wood chipper along with the Bill of
Rights sees dictatorial control of our
civilization and all that we will we
won't be able to say in principle they
can't do that or they don't have the
power to do that that can't be our
argument because we will have already
ceded that power and agreed and endorsed
the government in doing those things so
instead what what will our argument D be
I mean it's I'm not saying that you know
if you go along with this that means you
would have to agree to shutting down
society to address climate change but
what I'm saying is that your argument
that you can use will be very limited
and not nearly as powerful as it could
be because all we'll be able to do at
that point is debate whether it is
actually true that climate change poses
that kind of threat that's going to be
the debate it's it's going to be already
assumed at that point that if it does
pose that sort of threat then the
government can do all of these things
and more so then it's gonna come down to
does it pose that kind of threat it's
gonna be a battle of projections and
you're gonna have to come with your own
projections and say no my projections
say this isn't gonna happen yeah but the
problem is that the government will have
the consensus of the scientific
community on its side as we are told
over and over again 97% whatever it is
98% now you can point out that that
number is is misleading and it is but so
what if the government doesn't care
about that they're gonna say we have the
consensus of the scientific community we
have 97% that settles that
for all intensive purposes we're
shutting things down we are we're saving
the whole world from Armageddon if you
try to stand in the way that you hate
humanity you're gonna be responsible for
the death of so deaths of so many Billy
and so on and so on and so on there are
other possibilities just as plausible or
nearly as plausible imagine a future
democratic regime that declares gun
violence a national emergency and a
public health crisis and summarily
orders a confiscation of all quote
assault weapons or handguns now those of
us who obediently support the effective
suspension of the First Amendment even
up to the arrest of pastors who hold
worship services will have little ground
to stand on
when the Second Amendment is suspended I
mean if the one is negotiable and and
mutable why not the other right
especially if the government is saying
like we're not gotta confiscate all guns
just certain ones you don't need those
it's the same way all these people
yesterday we're telling me I I was
honestly I shouldn't be shocked by it
but I was we were talking about pastors
being arrested and I'll address this
more in the email section because as I
said lots of people disagree with me
lots of self-professed conservative
Christians are apparently totally on
board with arresting pastors but one
thing I heard over and over again is you
don't need to gather to meet you don't
need to meet you yeah you we have the
Internet just just meet on zoom' or
Skype or whatever watch a YouTube a
livestream don't you see how that's the
exact same argument people make with
guns where they say you don't need that
you don't need a in a quote assault
weapon you don't need it in a sense
they're right you know I did on a
day-to-day basis you don't need it but
that's not the point is it it's not a
point of you need it it's a point that
you have a right to it that's it and
what you hear from gun rights advocates
all the time is look I I'm I feel
horrible about about gun violence I feel
horrible when there's mass shootings but
if there was a mass shooting every day
in this country using these weapons I
still wouldn't agree to having them
confiscated why because I have a right
to it that's the argument right but if
the First Amendment is negotiable
immutable then why not the second all
we're gonna be able to do at that point
is argue that gun violence is not
actually a health crisis and an
emergency because we've all have already
agreed right that if it is a health
crisis and a legitimate emergency then
yeah forget about the Bill of Rights do
what you want governor we've already we
right now many of us are already
agreeing to that proposition as we speak
right now today so then are we'll all
we're going to be left with we're
arguing on their terms and we're saying
well yeah but if it was that then maybe
you could take that but it's not that
but once again the consensus of very
smart and powerful people will overrule
us they're gonna marshal this consensus
get the they have a whole consensus of
people saying no it is a it is a health
crisis it is an emergency in fact if you
do confiscate guns it will result in you
know whatever percentage reduction of
gun of gun violence we're gonna save X
number of lives and so let's do it right
I mean if you object to it if you object
to it then which of your family members
are you are you willing to have shot in
the head in a in an incident of gun
violence if you object to it which one
tell me same exact argument people are
using now we'll have nowhere else to go
no are no other argument to turn to the
most powerful argument that the
government in principle should not have
the power to take these sorts of actions
even if there really is a crisis will no
longer be available to us we will have
forfeited it we are forfeiting it right
now as we speak what if a future New
York governor occasio Cortes enjoying
the support of a Democrat run federal
government decides that the refusal of
certain churches in her state to perform
gay weddings is its own emergency
because of the mental and emotional
damage it does to people who are who are
who are refused can she close down those
places of worship until they pledged to
end their bigoted practices and why not
it's it's if it's really is an emergency
and besides these churches I mean you
you don't just like you don't need to
meet you don't need to you also don't
need
to to reject gay weddings you don't need
to it's not a need that you have you're
not gonna die if there's a gay wedding
in your church right so just do it and
if you don't do it we'll shut you down
you don't need it
if these possibilities seem implausible
to anyone then I would suggest that the
person who says they're implausible
hasn't been paying very close attention
to the rhetoric and language that these
people on the left use when making their
case pay attention to the kinds of
things they say they say things like
health crisis emergency epidemic these
are the words they use and they believe
it and millions of Americans believe it
and see it that way they've been setting
the stage for this kind of power grab
for many years now but I think the
coronavirus response and so you you
could rightly point out and smartly
point out that that well they they they
already would want to do this even
without the coronavirus they which is
exactly correct but I think the
coronavirus response and it's passive
acceptance by many Americans has made
what was once likely almost inevitable
and it certainly at least would seem to
have sped up the timeline of when we're
going to see these things happen all
right remember we only have 10 years
left right 10 years until the until
catastrophic consequences billions of
people dead if you really believe that
it actually but by the applying the
logic that we're seeing used today it
would actually make a lot of sense shut
everything down shut the hole shut the
hole shut civilization down to stop it
we're gonna move on to headlines but
first you know what's the secret to
building a good business building a real
a real business and when I say seek
we're not talking about get-rich-quick
schemes okay not pyramid schemes or
anything like that those things are very
appealing they make for nice little
YouTube videos where you can kind of
watch them and fantasize about having a
Lamborghini and all that kind of stuff
but what about building a real business
what's it all about success no matter
the cost is it about you know you have
to prioritize business over family have
a have a bad have a bad marriage you
have to be a you know it had to have no
ethics whatsoever you have to neglect
your kids no it doesn't have to be that
way
you can grow a business without
sacrificing your family without
sacrificing your character I want to
tell you about the Benham brothers the
venom brothers have over a dozen
businesses including a real estate
empire that spans over thirty five
states and they didn't sell their souls
for it
that's a good thing and if that name
rings a bell it's because you probably
are aware of this the Benham brothers
were slated for a reality TV show at HD
on HGTV and were cancelled because of
their commitment to conservative values
they sacrificed a lot of money you think
about how much money there is in it for
guys like the Benham brothers to be on
HGTV
well they sacrifice that because they
work in a sack because they sacrifice
that because the other option was to
sacrifice their values so called
business coaches tell you that your life
has to take a backseat to your hustle
but David and Jason Benham are proof
that that's simply a lie just this week
the Benham brothers launched their new
course expert ownership it's the model
they've used to build each one of the
businesses whether you're sick of the 9
to 5 or you have a 10 year old business
whatever it is expert ownership can help
you achieve your goals right now so to
celebrate the launch of their new course
they're offering 15% off to new members
you can check out a preview of their new
course and take advantage of that
discount over at Benham brothers dot-com
/ walsh that's been embroidered calm /
walsh benh a.m. brothers calm / walsh
head on over there to check out the new
course now you're not going to regret it
ok let's go to headlines the White House
is now projecting between 100,000 and
240,000 dead from the coronavirus even
with the measures that we put in place
Burks and fal'cie tell us that
this is better than the supposed two
million or so who would have died with
no mitigation efforts the models and
projections are continuously adjusted
which on one hand is understandable
right because nobody really knows the
future but on the other hand we are
bankrupting the country and driving
millions into financial ruin on the
basis of projections so the fact that
the projections keep changing is cause
for concern right but speaking of
projections as unreliable as they may be
here's here's my question has anybody
run a model or come up with a projection
to tell us what the bat body count might
be if we don't shut down the whole
economy but we also don't do nothing
because it seems like every model shows
us okay this is what would happen if we
shut everything down and this is what
happens if we do nothing and that's the
you know 200,000 dead verse two million
dead what they're telling us is that
with the mitigation efforts 100 to 200
thousand dead with nothing two million
okay but nobody is suggesting that we do
nothing I honestly have not heard that
proposed from anyone from any at least
from any certainly from any prominent
source I can't I can't guarantee that
there hasn't been somebody out on
Twitter somewhere saying that but I have
not seen any prominent person anyone of
note suggests that we do nothing in
response to the current of virus
epidemic so what these projections
they're they're giving us the total
shutdown versus on the other hand a
strategy that nobody has proposed so
what if we like everything thing down
but we also do things quarantine the
elderly the sick the systematic
encouraging mask use even mandating it
in certain situations along with other
hygiene measures etc what if we did that
what's the projection for that you know
you can't tell me that that that the
projection would be the same as if we
did nothing because because it's not
nothing obviously it's gonna have some
effect it's gonna do something so what's
the projection shouldn't that be what we
compared the lockdown projection to
wouldn't that give us a
your picture of the costs and benefits
the risks and rewards of one strategy
against the other how is it that in all
of our discussion in all of our
projections the idea of allowing the
economy to continue while also taking
serious mitigation steps hasn't even
been considered or discussed and how do
we not have projections for that it's
it's mind-boggling number two according
to dr. fallacy the CDC is now
considering actually urging Americans to
wear masks in public you may remember
that these medical authorities the CDC
the WHO others spent weeks months really
telling us that we shouldn't wear masks
and wearing masks won't accomplish
anything right we were told that now
thinking back on it of course it never
really made sense
I mean I'll admit I bought it when they
said it we had all these doctors say
yeah I was wearing masks won't do
anything now I thought to myself what it
doesn't what do you mean doesn't do it
right okay I mean I all right I mean I
don't know how these things work so if
you're telling me that doesn't do
anything then sure kind of it kind of
proves how we should oftentimes we
should just go with our common sense or
at least we should give our common sense
a fair hearing than we do or at least at
least I have done because of course you
think always Lyc if wearing a mask
doesn't do anything then why do doctors
wear them right and how could it be that
it would offer no protection obviously
if someone coughs and you're wearing a
mask you're at least better off with one
and then you would be without one you
can't tell me that it does nothing
whatsoever must do something it is some
kind of barrier and if you want to point
out that actually the masks are about
stopping you from spreading it not so
much stopping someone from spreading it
to you okay well then a mask would seem
to help there too well it turns out that
yeah if you if you were someone who just
used your common sense and said from the
beginning I don't believe that you're
looking pretty smart right now because
now we're being told by the CDC and
these same medical authorities that no
actually did I know we might change that
it's
turns out that masks actually might do
do do something they are they are
affected not a hundred percent effective
but effective in stopping the spread of
the virus even homemade masks I just
looked at a study that the New York
Times mentions one in a study and in a
recent article this is a study done
years ago about the I think was the flu
virus and they found that even a
homemade mask even something as crude as
like a t-shirt over your face obviously
that's not going to be as effective as a
medical mask but it's a hell of a lot
better than nothing both both when it
comes to not contracting the virus and
not spreading it which again when you
think about your common sense you think
well they they do tell us when we sneeze
or cough - you know - coffin to our
elbow right so that is essentially a
very crude homemade mask now if it's
important for us to do that and that
accomplishes something then it would
make sense that a mask of some kind
would accomplish at least at least that
much mitigation so it looks like the CDC
and who are going to come out and say
officially eventually that yeah actually
about that mask thing you should
probably wear them but then we have to
go back to the fact that these
organizations the organizations that
told us not to wear masks are the ones
that are at the forefront really of
shutting down the whole economy and it
does make you wonder how much you should
trust them especially when it's from
from how it looks right now it's not as
though these organizations were confused
now what we're being told now is that
well they did they discourage masks use
the Surgeon General among them I believe
the Surgeon General said just flat-out
they don't work not effective now they
knew that they do work it's just that
they were worried about Americans
hoarding surgical masks and medical
masks and that's why they told us that
so they lied to us they told a
straight-up lie for our for the greater
good for our benefit for our own good
they lied to us because they couldn't
trust us not to hoard and that makes
think what else might they be lying
about is there anything else they're
lying about for our own good I don't
know number three has Katie Hyde on
Twitter shows us and I'll show you these
screenshots the media has has has really
has this creepy tendency to latch on to
a talking point all at the same time
almost as if they're sitting around in a
smoky room conspiring and coming up with
their their plots in their talking
points in everything which of course
they aren't but you can see our
conspiracy theories come from sometimes
because because of how coordinated this
sort of stuff looks so these media
people all at once started using this
talking point that if a hundred thousand
people die from the quarter virus that
will be twice as many as died in the
Vietnam War twice as many as the Vietnam
War and as some of them are phrasing it
Trump will have then overseeing the
hundred thousand deaths which is twice
as much as the Vietnam War so you're
tying in Trump you're tying in the
Vietnam War now it's like we talked
about yesterday the media had yesterday
been blaring these headlines that more
people have died of the virus than died
during 9/11 so it's the same kind of
thing but but but why is that a
legitimate or helpful comparison and why
can you say more have died from the
virus than 9/11 but you can't say 27,000
fewer people have died from the virus
than then died during a mild flu season
both are true if you look at the numbers
right now both are true more have died
on 9/11 but significantly less at this
point have died then then died from the
flu both accurate statements but both
are equally as unhelpful in terms of
quantifying and putting this in
perspective but one of those unhelpful
analogies is blared all over the place
or comparisons as blared all over the
place while the other one if you dare if
you dare mention that you're gonna be
metaphorically stoned to death by the
media and with this vietnam war thing
100,000 is twice as many as died during
the vietnam war well yeah okay that's
but so what what does that mean we're
not talking about a war is that
comparison what is that comparison
supposed to do why tell us that why not
say a hundred thousand is twice as many
as die in a normal flu season well is it
because that actually makes the virus
sound a little bit less scary so if you
tell people that based on the
projections you know we might have you
can even say two to three times as many
people die as die from a normal flu
season when you put it like that it
sounds bad it sounds serious but then
you start thinking is that bad enough to
justify destroying the entire economy
and shutting everything down it's really
bad but I don't know you do you start
thinking that way when you frame it like
that but when you say twice as many will
die as died of Vietnam war then you
think well that was a war I mean you
think it's a this is so this is like
twice as bad as a war okay well that's
totally different so it's all about
conditioning the way we think about this
that's what the media is doing number
four this is this is good very inspiring
yesterday was the trans day of
visibility whatever that means and the
New Jersey state government sent out
this message it says in New Jersey our
strength is our diversity
hashtag trans day of visibility I just
want to call your attention to that
because I'm very glad that New Jersey is
taking time out in the middle of a
crisis to preach on to preach about
diversity and trans rights because then
it's a sort of thing we want our state
governments to be focused on right
that's that's that's that's what you're
that's what we're looking for we want to
talk about diversity right number five
reading now from ABC News headline
inmates charged with violent crimes
poised for release due to Cove in
nineteen two men allegedly involved in a
robbery where a New York City police
detective was killed and friendly fire
were among the violent offenders on the
list of inmates slated to be released
from the infamous Rikers Island jail
complex due to the krona virus pandemic
I'm not going to read this entire thing
in fact this is just one article about
them releasing prisoners are doing it in
New York City
they're doing it in California there was
I was looking at a tweet from tried to
find it here
let's see reporter in Boston tweet
Massachusetts highest court considering
if certain prisoner / detainees should
be released because of coronavirus
threats
25 investigates has learned a Bristol
County judge already released accused
child rapist Matthew Parris da tells me
his attorney argued asthma puts him at
risk now and the article ABC News even
says and the New York City is admitting
and this is you know we're so we're
talking about two different places here
but in the case of New York City they're
admitting that some of these people
being released do pose a high risk to
society
well we're gonna rule the release of
anyway an accused child rapist is
obviously a high risk individual but
we're gonna release him into society
because he is at risk because of his
asthma now I would tend to say if you
rape a child and he's only accused but
if he did it you know if you did it and
you rape the child and you have asthma
and you get coronavirus I'm not and I'm
not too worried about that I think
that's sort of on you and that's your
problem to deal with if you don't want
to go to prison where there might be a
corona virus epidemic that runs through
it maybe don't rape a child right that
would be my thought so what we're doing
across the country will be find in these
various states and localities is where
we're releasing prisoners and accused
child rapist and people who are known to
be serious threats to society we're
releasing them but we're arresting
pastors that makes a lot of sense
doesn't nothing to object to how could
you possibly object any of this no you
can't unless you hate everyone's
grandma's and you want to see everyone's
grandma's dead so it's only way you
could possibly object now let's move on
to your daily cancelation and before we
do wanna mention again what we've been
telling you about the
the all-access live show if you hadn't
had a chance to check out some of these
than tune in tonight at 8 p.m. Eastern
Time 5 p.m. Pacific in fact I believe I
will be the one I will be the one for
the all-access live show tonight and
it's just kind of a Q&A III enjoyed it's
a way of sort of getting past the
isolation and finding a little bit of
company for you and for us right it's
therapeutic for us as well it's part of
the reason we're doing this and it's
very relaxed it's not an official kind
of show the original idea was to have
the all-access shows roll out in a few
months only for all-access members but
because of this crisis that we're all in
we have rolled it out for all daily wire
members and we move the timeline up so
we're doing it now so if you're around
it tonight at 8:00 p.m. Eastern 5:00
p.m. 5:00 p.m. Pacific and you're a
daily wire member then join us for the
show and if you're not a daily wire
remember then become one and you can be
a part of that part of that experience
too okay for today for our daily
cancellation we're gonna cancel a
certain a certain mentality I guess
actually is maybe what we're canceling
instead of one particular individual and
that is the mentality the belief that
parents can't be teachers to their own
kids or shouldn't be last week I
mentioned that the Washington Post
posted an article that said that all of
this homeschooling that's going on
during the quarantine is gonna set it's
gonna set our kids back it's gonna set
back an entire generation of kids our
kids are gonna be set back by having
their own parents teach them and now
there's this viral post on Facebook I'm
not gonna put the guys in the name out
there because I'm not trying to send a
mob after him and I do think that he
means well right so I don't think
there's anything sinister going on here
but it's a viral post I saw it on
Facebook I've also had a bunch of people
email it to me and ask for my comment on
it here's the here's the post by this
principle that he put up on Facebook
says folks I've got about 20 years in
education and I'm a school principal I
cannot emphasize enough how important it
is for parents to not attempt to
replicate the school environment daily
routine or curriculum and instruction at
home
don't make up worksheets or download a
curriculum guide to follow at home don't
set recess breaks and don't
reconfigure your house to include to
include a classroom area you are not
being asked to homeschool your kids we
are at day two of a system shutdown this
was a couple weeks ago I guess but your
kids are probably still digesting the
fact they may not get to see their
friends and teachers in the foreseeable
future not to mention we are in the
middle of a global health crisis little
Suzy is not in any position to learning
new new math concept today modern
education isn't what we experienced as
kids the best thing you can do and the
closest to their educational reality is
to do things with them play a board game
do the dishes sing a song have them help
you do the laundry bake cookies dance in
the kitchen go sliding have a boil up in
the yard I don't know if that is and
have them shovel the driveway also give
them a loan time screen time and ask
them to tell you a story be with them
and show them that everything will be
okay you are their parents and family
members not their teachers whatever
happens we will make sure your child has
the tools needed to be to succeed in
school when the time comes for now be a
family okay means well right and some of
what he says here the principle is true
you should be doing things with your
kids and all the things that he mentions
that you should do with your kid I think
are great things to do I don't know what
a boil up is but it sound that sounds
good also the problem though cup a
couple big problems first of all just
the concept of a school administrator
helpfully telling parents what to do
with their own kids not even framing it
like here are some ideas or this is my
opinion but this is what you you need to
do as a parent with your own child now
and as I said school this is very common
with school administrators that they
have this kind of attitude where they're
gonna tell the parents what to do and
most of the time they they feel they
don't mean any harm by it
they're just try to help you out there
their school administrators they know
more than you do about your own kid and
about how to handle kids because they
work in a school and you don't so
there's gonna tell you what you need to
do just because it's well-intentioned
doesn't it doesn't make it right
it doesn't make it any less annoying or
any less troubling in fact that this is
the kind of attitude that school
administrators have and then there's the
second big problem of
you are their parents and not their
teachers that is the pun intended the
mother of all false dichotomies talk
about a false choice be their parent or
their teacher now actually as a parent
you're both you are not only a teacher
but you are their most important teacher
even if you don't homeschool even if
it's a normal situation and they're
going to school for five days a week
you're still their most important
teacher and the majority of lessons that
they take out of childhood they're gonna
take from you like it or not good or bad
you are their first primary most
important teacher by far so you are
their parent not their teacher that is
just wrong and again it's a common
attitude among school administrators
among some teachers not all in the
public school system were they kind of
the attitude they have to the parents is
hey butt out this is not your purview
you don't have a specialty you don't
have a degree in this I do and so don't
attempt to teach your own kids as if
it's rocket science right it's like it's
as if someone who doesn't have any
training tried to build a literal rocket
ship on their own okay in that case you
could say you are not a rocket science
dude scientists don't do that but
teaching your kid actually is not rocket
science not saying it's easy but you
know any parent can do it in fact
although what he says about not
replicating the public school
environment a lot of that is true I
agree with that maybe not for the
reasons that he says it but it's true I
think it's one of the advantages of
homeschooling is that you don't have to
have that kind of uber structured
environment although you still do want
some structure and some of the things
that you do you know what it was you
mentioned it recess breaks and that sort
of thing reconfiguring your house to
include a classroom area I mean that's
we homeschool we have we have a
classroom area downstairs I think that's
that is good stuff to do
but at the end of the day as a parent
you make those decisions okay let's go
to emails we have a little bit of time
to read through some of these I've got a
bunch of why I'm wrongs today and we'll
go through them quickly as a kid this is
from Jeffrey says Matt you chose the
wrong horse to ride with that pastor
story that pastor is a charlatan in it
for the money that's the only reason he
held the service usually you criticize
snake oil salesmen like him well yeah
Jeffrey bets that's not really relevant
if it's true I don't know the pastor we
talked about yesterday that got arrested
I don't know anything about him not a
thing that's the first time I've heard
his name maybe he's a charlatan maybe
he's not that's not the point he's not
the horse I'm riding okay I'm riding the
First Amendment and I'm saying that we
should still have the right to hold a
worship service without getting arrested
charlatan or not from Sean I'm a
conservative and Christian but I thought
you were extremely irresponsible in your
commentary parentheses show and op-ed
yesterday read Church closings pastors
who hold church gatherings are being
foolishly reckless we have to speak out
against this behavior that puts others
at risk and not endorse it as you have
done that's my two cents still love the
show thank well Sean I think that you're
missing the point a little bit I never
said that I think pastors should be
holding worship services I didn't say
that whether doing so is reckless as you
say is not my point
in fact many churches most it seems to
me chose to shut down voluntarily before
the government got involved my church
did all the churches in my area that I'm
that I'm aware of
shut down before it was forced on them
by the state and you may have noticed I
never criticized any of those churches I
didn't bring the issue up until
yesterday why is that because I think
there's a big difference because to me
there's there's a big difference between
churches choosing to follow social
distancing guidelines as most of them
were and the government enforcing those
guidelines at gunpoint
once that happens I think we have a
problem a huge problem
and when I say gunpoint a lot of people
took issue with me I kept saying the
government is enforcing this at gunpoint
yes they are everything the government
does is at
gunpoint because the implication is
always we've got guys with guns and and
and they don't have to actually brandish
it every time the government uses force
every time the government makes an
arrest it forces a law it has always
done at gunpoint I'm not saying the
government should never enforce any law
I'm just saying that's the reality and
if they're shutting down churches they
are doing it yes at gunpoint from
laura's says dear man I've been a fan
for a while I'm a conservative Christian
but I strongly disagree with the
direction you've gone recently the
corona virus is a public health crisis
and the government is doing what must be
done to curb it whining about your
freedoms and the First Amendment just
feels petty to me and it seems like you
don't appreciate that lives are at stake
okay Laura well you say you're a
conservative a Christian you agree with
the government's summarily labeling all
churches non-essential closing them
indefinitely and arresting pastors who
hold worship services I just feel like
that position seems to be contrary to
nearly every principle I associate with
conservatism and that's where I stand
from Ryan says today is the first time
I've ever questioned your status as the
all-knowing King of the universe however
you're dead mistaken insofar as you
think it's unconstitutional to suspend
worship services under employment
division verse Smith it is perfectly
constitutional to restrict religion so
long as the law is quote neutral and
generally applicable as to its potential
impact on every citizen equally and does
not target a specific race group or
religion it does not violate the First
Amendment even were even where the state
interest is trivial the government may
adopt restrictions as long as the law
fits the after mentioned parameters the
greatest must fall to be humbled
okay Ryan well first of all I'm aware
that the courts would probably allow
this but that really doesn't interest me
very much I have to be honest with you
every time we're talking about something
like this and someone says well the
court said it was okay all right I don't
really care the courts allow a lot of
things that are clearly wrong clearly to
rinette tyrannical clearly outside the
scope of what the law originally
intended the courts to remind you have
decided that you have a god-given right
to kill your child you could tell me all
day the court said it's okay I don't
care doesn't make it okay
now I understand practically speaking it
gives the government the authority to do
it but also remember that the judicial
branch is part of the government so this
is the government giving itself
authority to do things so the fact that
said what you're basically telling me is
the government has given itself the
authority to do it therefore it has the
authority I understand that that is
practically speaking how it works but I
still don't think it's right
okay that's that's it my argument is
that arresting pastors banning worship
services banning people from gathering
indefinitely as is happening this
clearly represents an annihilation of or
at least a suspension of the First
Amendment the First Amendment guarantees
as an inalienable right the very thing
the government right now today will
arrest you for doing now the courts can
say that's okay I just disagree I think
it's clearly wrong and it's obviously it
obviously represents a suspension of
those rights nobody wants to see it that
way but the First Amendment says you can
do it right now the government is saying
if you do you'll be arrested how can
they both exist in this how can we
pretend that the First Amendment is
still right now active and functional
while you'll be arrested for doing the
things that the First Amendment says you
have a right to do but as for the
Court's decisions there you know you say
neutral are generally applicable well I
would argue that the shutdowns and
quarantines are neither of those the
government is subjectively deeming
certain businesses and organizations as
essential while labeling others
non-essential then closing the ones that
it has decided are non-essential so now
the government says well you know if
you're non-essential we can shut you
down who decides if it's not essential
they do and there's not any real
calculus here it's just it and it
appears to be very arbitrary so for
example in my state abortion clinics are
essential beer stores are essential fast
food drive-through is essential
Starbucks
drive-through is essential all of those
things are essential I disagree I don't
think they're essential and I think a
church is more essential
they're at least equally as in essential
depending on how you look at it right
but that's just my opinion and it's the
government's opinion is or these in or
these individual you know governors or
whoever's making these decisions
depending on what level we're talking
about now I'm not arguing by the way
that we should shut down all those
places I just mentioned I'm glad that
some of them get to stay open at least
there's some semblance of an economy
still going so I wouldn't want to see
those shut down I'm just saying that
obviously I mean we need when you talk
about they're shutting out if there's a
there's a there's a pandemic and
supposedly millions are gonna die if we
don't do and you're keeping the beer
stores open the beer distributors come
on I'm glad they're open I have taken
advantage of that and gone and gotten
some beer during this okay it's helped
me get sort of get through the difficult
and trying time but essential obviously
not so if you're really taking this
seriously if this is really necessary to
stop the the pandemic then you would
shut that down because so you're saying
it's it it's it's worth the risk I went
to a liquor store the other day and
there was easily I don't know you have
20 people in there milling around it's
essential okay
quart Mandic but the court will say it's
alright I find the court says that I
don't agree but thank you for that email
anyway and thank you for all the emails
I as I said I'm I have to say I'm I
shouldn't be shocked I am a little bit
shocked that I didn't expect I expected
an argument I I didn't think I was
saying anything that would be very
popular nothing I say I guess was
popular it seems like but I was I wasn't
expecting just based on the reaction
I've gotten from emails and things it
seems to be like 70/30 against my
position and in favor of arresting
pastors and that's just you know that is
an anecdotal based on just the feedback
I've gotten personally but I was
surprised by that I have to say we'll
leave it there though thanks for
watching everybody thanks for listening
Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
our supervising producers are Mathis
Glover and Robert Sterling our technical
producer is Austin Stevens edited by
Dani D'Amico and our audio is mixed by
Robyn Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 hey everybody its Andrew
Clavin host of the Andrew Clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the American Republic is
collapsing the end of days is
approaching and the moon has turned to
blood but on the Andrew Clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the Andrew Clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me Andrew clip
[Music]